[Music]
here we go
who are these unstoppable warriors we're
the mitchells the only people who can
save the world
the mitchell sources of machines is an
animated movie about a teenage girl
who's leaving for college for the first
time in her family who's trying to hold
on to her in the midst of a robot
apocalypse that threatens the world
hi my name is mike randa i'm the
co-writer and director of the mitchell
versus the machines
this is a scene in the beginning of the
movie and this is right after rick and
katie have this big argument that leads
to their big falling out katie's excited
to leave for college and never look back
and rick sort of looks to the past and
how warm and sweet it was and he was
desperately trying to get that back
[Music]
this scene was in the script we were
talking about trying to have a visual
symbol of their relationship and we were
trying to sort of figure out how to make
it more visual and tangible and then i
remember jeff threw this kind of dusty
moose on a whiteboard
right here
is this like dusty moose he drew and
then we thought that was such a great
symbol because she hasn't thought about
it she even throws it away and we were
like oh my god it'd be so brutal if you
found something that you gave to your
kid that meant a lot to you that they
just threw away when they left for
college so it was a way to try to feel
closer to rick we wanted the audience to
want what he wanted which is like i've
got to save this relationship
we really wanted the scene to look like
it was a real teenage girl's room which
is a disaster
for her to have all of these strange
sort of idiosyncratic things from like
weird b-movie posters that she loves
these little puppets that she makes a
part of this character is just having
her creativity sort of exploding out of
the frame in every moment
[Music]
it was a real challenge to get the hood
on her it's so funny in 3d animation the
weirdest things are hard and expensive
and they were like you got one hoodie
shot
make it count
we're like what two of the hardest
things to do in 3d are hair and cloth
simulation when cloth is interacting
with hair
it's oh it's a bonanza of money
so we tried to choose our hoodie shot
well and this is an area where we really
wanted her to feel bad and down so we
chose this for the one moment
[Music]
why is he like this
why is he like this
jeff wrote the lines why is he like this
why is she like this which nicely sort
of connected the characters through
editing it was also in that shot really
important for her to be looking at a
picture of her and her dad when they got
along well but you also want to show the
audience that she too
once valued this relationship and she
subtly would like it to return to the
way it used to be
it was really important for the audience
to know she doesn't want a relationship
with her
did you dad to her yet
no not yet
the performances in an animated film are
a handshake
between the voice actors and the
interviewers the voice actors come first
and then the animators animate to the
voice track and this scene is filled
with great performances the animator's
whole job is making the characters act
like real people linda she's nervous and
she doesn't want to confront her husband
but she also feels like she needs to say
something so she's like rubbing her hand
and avoiding eye contact rick is washing
dishes
there's nice little finger tap there
one of the animators added that it was
so exciting because it meant the movie
was a little bit more alive and some
artist was bringing something new to it
these are digital puppets
they're not human beings so any tool you
can use to try to make them seem more
real is like
money in the bank seeing the animator
add something like that makes me so
happy
you just broke her laptop i mean
look we haven't had a good family
picture in years because you two are
always arguing
huh well what about that one that came
with the frame
this picture we had in a screening and
we loved this picture and made everyone
laugh and then we couldn't get the
rights to it and then i hired this guy
called the wolf and he was able to track
them down
and we got them to sign a release and we
were able to use in the movie
i know you can do this
this is the first shot we locked in the
movie one of our artists i think it was
toby wilson did this amazing color key
that looked exactly like we wanted the
whole movie to look and then we worked
with mike lasker and his amazing team at
imageworks and mike came from
spiderverse so he knew the pipeline of
3d animation to match a painting exactly
so this is the first um shot that we did
for the movie and i'm super proud of it
[Music]
this scene is really dark
it really sort of makes you feel how
devastated rick is we did this color key
and the entire studio revolted against
us saying this is too dark
it has to be this dark because rick is
in a bad place emotionally and you have
to really feel that and also when you
watch tv at night it's dark and i i
think it really does help the scene
a lot of the reasons why these shots are
exteriors is because rick kind of
romanticizes nature and the relationship
he had with his daughter was that she
did everything he liked to do so he
liked to go into nature so she's going
with him and so when he looks at the
past he sees all those moments and he's
like that's what we need to get back but
what he really needs to get back is sort
of you know seeing his daughter and
seeing who she's become and the movies
that she makes and the and the person
that she is now
we wanted the scene to be entirely from
rick's point of view this is his whole
motive is to get back to these days and
seeing them kind of through rose-colored
glasses a little bit the shots are
really overexposed as we were trying to
get that feeling of what home movies
really look like and they often have bad
lighting
i love that piece of acting um that was
um pitched by alan hawkins who has a kid
of his own and it's just like
but it's something i've never seen in an
animated movie it's something you would
never think to animate but all of the
team brought so many new ideas like this
to the film i think in the storyboards
they just hugged
and now the mitchell family talent shows
[Music]
we literally added this scene of them
singing to justify this act three payoff
we had with them singing together at the
end of the movie to try to make it feel
cohesive
bye katie are you excited for cam this
is the part where you see that rick is
actually a really good dad um this is
one of the most important scenes in the
movie and it took so long to tweak the
dialogue to be just right and have rick
sort of give her this totem this thing
that's really important to him but also
he's being a goofball
him trying to sort of do anything he
could to to cheer his daughter up and
get him to stop crying and get her to
feel
happy and confident about leaving for
camp instead of scared
you know how to say i love you in moose
language let me just
don't you laugh come on you're supposed
to be sad
[Music]
i love that shot of him sadly looking at
his reflection
[Music]
[Music]
all right let's fix it
he stands up and he says let's fix it
that's the action that basically
inspires the rest of the movie
i'm really proud of this scene i've read
so many people say i'm 14 minutes in and
i'm already crying and every time i'm
like oh it's the scene this is the scene
i like check 14 minutes in and i think
it's really a credit to the team sort of
everyone firing on all cylinders i think
every single person who touched it made
it better it's easy for me to say
because i'm just proud of all the things
that the other artists did
they did all the good stuff and i just
sort of was a enthusiastic cheerleader
for it
you